what was the big thing you got that you
just it lit up your parents eyes you
could tell like well holy crap our son's
done something right here so i i i was
comparing stories with some friends uh
a little while ago when did you make it
when do you feel that you made it like
when was your
here i am and right for me it was
every next step i took i thought
well i made it clearly one life to live
i've made that
and then i'd put something in the
distance like if i can get on
the late show with david if i can get on
david letterman i i'll have made it
and then you and then i did it happened
i had a dream come true i couldn't
believe it
and then you set another goal and you
say if i get i'll make it that then i'll
have made it
i need to go to your psychiatrist or if
you don't have one i need to go to you
i need to pay you to talk because we
just come from two different places
you know when i first got my first show
in um in la
uh i thought i'd made it i drove cross
country with all my guys we wore
overalls and we said we're not changing
our overalls till we hit vegas we had a
i had a vote
runners i guess we were dex midnight
runners
yeah so we changed all our clothes in
vegas and we drove out there and i go
i've done it man i got this kid from
small
town went to new york did some
off-broadway shows and
now he's got a tv show and i thought
everything changes now
and i wasn't the lead i was like the
sixth lead and i had you know not that
well it was ranked like 130 out of 132
one of the worst shows on television and
by the way thank you but here and you
know what's funny is
it wasn't just no one paid attention to
me
it was that my parents my family my
own family would even talk [ __ ] about it
they would say god that show looks just
awful doesn't it do they shoot that on
what do they shoot that on i'm like
uh video i i don't know it's like oh my
gosh it's just the dialogue it's just
awful isn't i'm like oh my god this is
i have not made it this is
and so i feel like i was always trying
to get ahead like
okay what about this show oh my god
we're on the subways wherever they
canceled
so it's always and i find that now that
i'm 48 years old and i'm like
well michael it's not about what you're
doing it's about how you feel inside and
what you feel that you've done and your
accomplishments and what is that mr hand
what is it that you've i don't know why
i started talking like that